hello and welcome to this video playing
our rosters said Cyprus yep okay who had
to rush wow that's rare hmm okay nighty
and the end my takes I guess that
probably g3 I don't think I can refute
it directly no this is okay though he
has taken very early on the form I think
should be three is good in this position
i'm not mistaken queen bee three okay
let's go back you can go tonight see
forward this is not this is not so great
damn 27
Jan so how do I continue here some have
some pressure on that porn it's an even
night be three comes into consideration
directly attacking ad ok I'll go for
that okay do for this
night is it again I wanted to play half
Bishop d5 here just snatching the pawn
and now I see that he probably has 93
every 395 Luke t5 Queen takes d5 so not
so great and so maybe this one p tending
to take on f6 and then take on d5
now if you think he may be four was a
move but playing a quick move now and
then it's not so bad
I have to be somewhat somewhat quick it
doesn't help that he plays such an and
yeah and some new water if I lose on
time I wonder if I'm threatening efore
here now after you for when he takes
with a pawn I have a nice discovered
attack with the bishop might be I
definitely have Bishop f6 and a capture
on d5 on the agenda
it's difficult now for him okay he just
okay this is about the least move you
can think of him the least likely move
that that it really shouldn't work at
all I take on e4 and take on g7 so where
is the trick then I mean he has to think
about this you see some and I don't see
and I mean there is no night discovery
here night a three or something it just
just doesn't work
now 96 or something no okay I mean let's
see there's also Bishop c5 which is we
need six or things saves material so
I'll grab them and now I think I'll take
I'll just take care 93 I can take with
the Queen and I have queen age 6 now I
really doesn't have 95 or something like
that I can play Queen to h6 queen age 6
should save the day threatens made on g7
and the Queen on age three
black resigns it has to be very wee bit
shocked by 94 after that long thought
because this is actually a principal
threat here of course to and he just
gave me that idea for for nothing ok so
this is valid that capture on divorce is
really weird move maybe I can already
try to refute it with Queen deform I
mean why this heck 32 lb up right here
maybe you for yeah but this is this is a
a theoretical position that's not so bad
actually yeah hmm yeah yeah maybe he can
tonight okay this is slightly inferior
to rush here I don't know I don't cannot
really believe and black set up but it
wasn't it wasn't that clear yeah and if
all of us maybe already an option but
the engine gives screens you want as the
best move it gives and wider pretty
substantial advantage it's simply very
difficult to hold them with the center
now anymore this is directly losing but
now the computer wants to play Bishop g4
back probably because that prevents you
for for the time being I can try to to
win something here like this but there
are counter tricks
maybe I do something else this is given
by the computer that doesn't look so
convincing one screen be one the point
is probably that this now is not good
ugu form yeah that's good for what okay
well this is this is just losing you
know this is birthing made and looking
at the Queen so it's a forcing the Queen
trade when black is a full look down
okay thanks for watching